okay we now have to talk about cnn's
role in
this second democratic primary debate
there is no other way to say it
cnn's production and management of the
presidential debate over the last two
nights
was disgusting there's no other way to
say it it was everything that is wrong
with political discourse and with
corporate media i mean it just
that they could have done nothing worse
that i can imagine
other than cartoonishly terrible things
that would never really happen and i'm
really talking about
everything the format was a disaster
their handling of the digital rights of
the content itself
was an absolute embarrassment this
really was one of the worst produced
debates from start to finish that i can
remember and if this is a signal
about what to expect from now until the
last debate of 2020
democracy and discourse is in serious
trouble which you probably already knew
and it's hard to know even where to
start i told you yesterday
and again in today's debate wrap-up that
uh they tried desperately to create fake
drama not even hiding the totally
base and brazen ways in which they were
just trying to get candidates to call
each other out and
first of all much like with the nbc
debate format
that's really the only way that you can
sort of do well as i've talked about
when you have a format which
allows for very short answers even
shorter and sporadic rebuttals sometimes
as short as 15 seconds
all you can do is try to bring these
kill shot gotcha moments
that is by design and the format
reinforces that and the moderators
regularly trying
to pit the candidates against each other
not in a way that really helps us
explore issues and ideas listen to me
talk about ideas
but only in a way that encourages these
attempts at kill shots
additionally the debates were way too
long the first one ran about two hours
and forty minutes i think the second
night was about two hours and forty five
but understand
that on night one the first question
wasn't asked until 23 minutes had
already gone by
they started with these sports team
introduction like videos
they included a commercial before you
even had the first questions
they did introductions very slowly
bringing the candidates out onto the
stage
they did opening statements which tell
us nothing and then on the second night
27 minutes went by before the first
question was even asked
the opening statements should be done
away with the sportsification of the
debates
should be stopped and it's just way too
long
with such little substance the second
night
going even longer and again almost a
half
hour before you saw a question it
started at eight
you could have tuned in at 8 30 and have
missed only
part of the first question this is an
embarrassment
the response window's obviously too
short cutting everyone off sometimes
after even
only 15 seconds anyone who's serious
about learning about the positions of
the candidates could not have possibly
done it from this debate
and i know the nbc one wasn't anything
to write home about
but the cnn one was even worse the
moderators were way too much of a
presence almost like
they just wanted to hear themselves talk
there are already too many candidates
competing for air time and we've got the
moderators also in that competition
and then half the questions were
premised on republican talking points
for so-called
liberal media which cnn is accused of
being
they did a hell of a job of asking the
questions that republican would have
republicans would have wanted asked in
the ways
that republicans would have asked them
and then as you know
the digital rights management cnn shut
down my stream
on night one on youtube they shut down
many other streams from
semi-prominent news and politics
youtubers they gave us a copyright
strike jeopardizing our entire youtube
account
commandeering an entire day of my time
yesterday
ultimately getting that strike repealed
by the way which is a good thing
and the dnc shouldn't stand for this the
dnc is complicit
and the dnc should be demanding that
whichever network gets to brand the
debate
and produce the debate they should be
forced to allow it for repurposing
as if it were the state of the union
address on c-span i
actually disagree with debates for
public office even being held by private
organizations but if they are
they must be treated like a public
service event we're picking the next
president
or at least the person who will compete
to be the next president in the general
election
it can't be a sporting event for profit
at the exclusion of everybody else
it was an absolute and total
embarrassment the next one is in
september
abc news univision together are running
it
i really hope it's not another
disgusting atrocity like what we saw on
cnn the last two nights
but it probably will will be let me know
what changes you think
would be the most uh positive that could
be made to the way these debates have
been produced so far
i'm on twitter at d pacman and the show
is on twitter at david pakman show
do you stand for the environment and for
women's rights there's a phone company
that stands with you
and that's credo mobile credo is the
only phone company in america
that supports the same causes you do
causes like
fighting to stop climate change to
protect reproductive freedom
and immigrant rights credo donates a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars every
month to groups like
rainforest action network planned
parenthood
the aclu while other phone companies are
spending millions
to push through mega mergers and fund
right-wing politicians
you make choices every day about where
to spend your money
so make your mobile phone one of those
choices switch to credo mobile now
and as a reward you'll get 12 pints
of ben and jerry's ice cream that's a
pint a month for 12 months
you'll also get coverage on the nation's
largest most reliable network
along with low rates and a complete
selection of smartphones
including the latest models from the top
brands
make the switch today go to credo.com
pacman or enter the offer code pacman at
checkout that's
credo dot com slash
p-a-k-m-a-n